some breaking news regarding a party
that allegedly took place in the downing
street garden in may of last year let's
head to westminster and speak to
john craig
john this is something that dominic
cummings the prime minister's former
aide actually alluded to
on friday tell us more
this is the party indeed that dominic
cummings in a blog on friday afternoon
said it should
not happen he said
a senior number 10 official invited
people to socially distanced drinks in
the garden a social event that should
not have happened mr cummings claimed we
now know uh that the invitation came
from martin reynolds he is a uh a senior
civil servant in number 10 the principal
private secretary and uh two two really
astonishing developments this evening
first of all
an email has been leaked to itv news
which actually reprints the invitation
to the drinks it says this it shows the
email
it says um
the the email says um that you are
invited to socially distanced drinks in
the garden it says in view of the uh
summer weather uh he says uh he says
that we're invited to uh drinks in the
garden um here we are i've got it here
it says
the email says hi all after what has
been an incredibly busy period it would
be nice to make the most of the lovely
weather and have some socially distant
drinks in the number 10 garden this
evening please please join us from 6 p.m
and
bring your own booze
according to itv news 40 people gathered
in the garden that evening eating picnic
food and drinking
crucially they included the prime
minister and his wife carrie johnson now
mr cummings said uh that uh the the the
uh that particular uh
event mr cummings claims that he said it
was wrong he said that he and at least
one other special adviser said this
seemed to be against the rules the
coveted rules and should not happen we
were ignored says mr cummings well this
morning after reports at the weekend
suggesting that the pm and his wife
carrie attended this event remember this
is the 20th of may not the one we've
seen photos of on the 15th of may listen
to what the prime minister said today
when he was asked quite specifically
were you and carrie johnson at this
party on the 20th of may last year
i want to ask you about the latest
allegations on christmas parties did you
and carrie attend the downing street
party that was organized by martin
reynolds on the 20th of may all
all of that as you know is the subject
of a uh a proper uh investigation by sue
gray so have you already been
interviewed by sue gray and if not do
you object to her question you again
about this uh all that subject for an
interview for investigation by sue grey
so john the prime minister neither
confirming nor nor denying and of course
let's remember what the rules were
people were banned from meeting more
than one person outdoors at the time
they were indeed yes and i think i'm
right in saying that oliver dowden the
tory party chairman had said as much uh
that very day now uh the labour party
has responded uh with angela raynor uh
saying that um boris johnson
boris johnson has consistently shown
he's no regard for the rules he puts in
place for the rest of us he's trying to
get officials to take the fall for his
own mistakes that's in response to
reports that uh mr reynolds is going to
be the fall guy for this but he sets a
tone for the way downing street and the
rest of gov government operates
at the time this party took place as
angela rayner key workers on the front
line were working round the clock to
keep us all safe people suffered
loneliness and loss in unimaginably
tough circumstances and for the majority
of the country our freedom was limited
to a daily walk uh she says labour has
welcomed sue gray's inquiry that's the
one the prime minister referred to but
we need confirmation this latest
revelation and any other parties not yet
revealed by press investigations will be
covered by her probe now
i mentioned two startling disclosures
the second is the response from a senior
government source inside number 10 which
seems to suggest that mr reynolds is
indeed being set up as the fall guy this
is a senior government source on the
talking about the reynolds email
speaking to sky news a short time ago
reynolds job was to protect staff who
were looking to him to lead them through
something nobody had ever done before
this is just a perfect example of how he
failed at it
the public are right to be outraged that
the one rule for them one rule for us
some people in number 10 felt
uncomfortable about it
at the time but the truth is nobody ever
got to grips with working in number 10
while the rest of the country were made
to work from home reynolds did not
protect people from the spread of covert
in the building and he and others didn't
think through the consequences of those
actions
he was in charge of it all he has to be
held accountable for it that is a senior
government source speaking one would
assume with the authority of the prime
minister given uh the explosive nature
of that attack on mr reynolds from the
very heart of downing street
it seems of inconceivable uh that mr
reynolds can survive in his job and uh
that uh he will perhaps be out of a job
by the end of the evening that is
despite
uh number 10 saying earlier today he's
not going um
so um a huge pressure on a senior
downing street civil servant looks like
he is going to have to carry the can for
this uh but now we have uh the uh
confirmation of the invitation to uh to
uh downing street civil servants after
what has been an incredibly busy period
it'd be nice to make the most of the
lovely weather and have some socially
distanced drinks in the number 10 garden
this evening please join us from 6 p.m
and bring your own booze
40 people gathered in the garden well
the prime minister now has more
explaining to do up to now he's saying
it's up to sue gray the senior civil
servant who's investigating this to
carry out her inquiry uh but uh he has
not denied in the uh
little exchange we've just heard that he
and his wife were there this piles
pressure on the prime minister uh it
does look as though at the top of the
downing street machine they do seem to
be putting the blame fairly on and
squarely on a civil servant martin
reynolds his position this evening looks
precarious could well be that by the out
of the by the end of the evening he will
have at least offered his resignation
and quite likely have it accepted as
well